at one time
square in a protest for democracy in
nation when the army threatened to
intervene their convoys were halted by
ordinary citizens it all seemed very
friendly there were a few isolated
clashes giving no hint of the carnage to
come while in the square itself they
even constructed a replica of the Statue
of Liberty as the protest seemed to
peter out without bloodshed but on
Saturday night the Army finally acted
with disastrous consequences it was to
be one of the darkest hours in recent
Chinese history the sticks and stones of
the students proving no real match
against the military might of one of the
world's biggest armies the soldiers
showed no mercy in opening fire
indiscriminately into the crowds
no one knows exactly how many died the
official Chinese version claims only 300
people were killed in Tiananmen Square
all of them soldiers unofficial accounts
say the death toll exceeded 7,000
whatever the truth no one had believed
the People's Army would actually open
fire on the people themselves Chinese
state television showed these pictures
of an ambushed army convoy blaming
student counter-revolutionaries amidst
all the turmoil alone act of heroism I
was so moved today by the bravery of
that individual that stood alone in
front of the tanks rolling down rolling
down the Main Avenue there and and I
heard some speculation on the television
I what is it that what is it that gives
a young man the strength gives him the
courage to stand up in front of a column
of Tanks in right there in front of the
front of the world and I'll tell you it
was very moving because all of us have
seen the bravery and the determination
of the students and the workers seen
their commitment to peaceful protest and
that that image I think is going to be
with us for a long time soldier was
firing indiscriminately into the crowd
and three young girl students knelt down
in front of him and begged him to stop
firing and he killed them and then all
gentlemen put his hand up because he
wanted to cross the road and he shot him
and then his magazine was done with
empty so he tried to reload and the
crowd jump came in and hanging from tree
the 27th army responsible for the
slaughter in the square have been
branded the butchers of Beijing
[Music]
forty-eight hours after their assault
the soldiers were still firing at will
against unarmed civilians creating
terror in the streets of Beijing tanks
deployed in defensive positions around
Tiananmen Square as word spread that
other army units loyal to the
discredited though moderate communist
party leader Zhao Jie aang were heading
towards the capital for a showdown the
crowds were still out on the streets
despite the danger showing their
contempt for the army but fearful of
what might happen next
protesters still hijacked and sent
vehicles alight but the expected battle
of Beijing never happened the 27th army
has been withdrawn and other soldiers
moved up into the heart of the city
where all week the clean-up operation
has been going on
the square itself remains cordoned off
but the fresh troops are under strict
orders to be friendly towards the people
now today in Beijing the mood is one of
shock and disbelief
- that what has happened during the past
six days life is returning to something
like normal but with a pervading army
presence a time to reflect on the
horrors of what happened but a time also
for those who lived through it which
they will never forget